Merhabalar şimdi buraya gelirken kadın
mevzusunu açsam mı açmasam mı diyordum
çok yeni belli oldu benim Denizli'ye
geleceğim niye kadın konusunu Konuşayım
mı konuşmayayım mı diye düşündüm çünkü
medyadaki 20
kadın konusu açıldığı anda reytinglerin
düştüğü gibi insanların kaçtığını
görüyorsunuz Niye benim teorim şu Çünkü
hepimiz bir kere bu ülkede üç kadından
bir tanesi şiddetin bir formuna maruz
kalıyor dünyada da bu istatistikler çok
parlak değil o çok öykünerek baktığımız
İskandinav ülkelerinde dahi ki covid de
şiddet konusunda çalışmalar bunu da
gösterdi Dolayısıyla kadın konusu
insanların içini
karartıyor yaşadıkları yaşamadıkları
gördükleri görmedikleri meseleler
depreşiyor ve insanlar bir şekilde
korkuyorlar kaçıyorlar Ama bende de
Arnavut damarı var ya Dolayısıyla ben
hep İnadına inadına kadın tarihine
Aslında kadının tarih sahnesinden
silinmesini yazıyorum çiziyorum
konuşuyorum Dolayısıyla bugün Aslında
benim neredeyse 20 yıllık bir obsesyonun
takıntım hikayesini size anlatacağım Bu
biraz da şöyle başladı Ben tarihi okudum
evet
Eee ama tarihten çok böyle müzeleri
gezmeyi seven yeni bilgiler edinmeyi
seven Heyecanlı bir çocuktu sonra
eee işte sanıyorum Bir 15 sene önce
falan Selanik'te arkeoloji müzesine
gittim ve oradaki iki baş arkeolog
kadınla tanıştım
onlarla otururken sohbet ederken e
ilişkilerimizi yudumlarken
dediler ki ah size ne kadar böyle huşu
içinde bakıyoruz biz işte Antik Yunan
tarihçileri olarak arkeologları olarak
çünkü sizin anadolunu ana tanrıçalar
Diyarı sizin Anadolu işte kibel elerin
astelin Arın
iştarın Şahmaran lın Diyarı oysa
bizde işte Zeus Apollo Posey donlar var
hatta bir tarihçi şunu söyler bütün
Yunan mitolojisine yani Yunan mitolojisi
deyince küçümsemeyin o mitoloji demek
aslında Dinler Tarihi
demek Yunan mitolojisine
Zeus'un
işte birlikte olmayı hayal ettiği erkek
ve kadınları Eee kovalama kataloğundan
ibarettir Dolayısıyla Hani Zeus gibi
böyle Ater kil toplumun panteonunda baş
Tanrı öyle olacak Oysa bize bakınca
dediğim gibi böyle E artemis'in işte o
herkes Onun ne olduğunu bilmiyor erkek
yumurtalıkları asılı heykellerinin böyle
baş tapınakları dikildiği Eee
Şahmaran'ın Hayat bağışladığı bir
Coğrafyadan bahsediyorlardı Ben de bunun
üzerine uzun zaman boyunca
mitolojiye girdim mitoloji genellikle
çok E küçümsenen bir konudur sanki böyle
bir seri masal olarak adlandırılır ama
masal değildir Sonuçta insanın en temel
sorularını neden buradayız e bizim
misyonumuz ne insanlık nasıl doğduğu
bütün korkularımızı anksiyeteler imizi
meraklar mızı heyecanlar ımızı
tutkularımız Aslında açıklamaya çalışan
bir seri
Eee hikayeden ibaret eee bir Aslında
Konu başlığı ve dediğim gibi Dinler
Tarihi Dolayısıyla bunlara girdikçe de
kadın tarihe tarihine olan bakışım
değişti derken Namlı Bir dergiden bir iş
teklifi aldım dediler ki işte her ay Biz
de yazmanı istiyoruz Ben de dedim tamam
yazarım ama her ay bir kadının
portresini bir kadının hikayesini
yazacağım Çünkü bu Namlı dediğim
dergilere baktığınızda ki eminim pek
çoğunuz biliyordur ülkemizde 3 be tane
böyle popüler tarih dergisi var Hep işte
yok malazgit Savaşı yok şu generalin
başarısı vesaire vesaire savaşlar erkek
Egemen toplumun kahramanları bol bol kan
gözyaşı ve ter var orada kadın kadın pek
yok kadın tarihte genel olarak
bildiğimiz üzere garnitür gibi bir bir
yeri var ha ama bu arada tabii tarihin
ünlü kadınları var şimdi size sorsam
mesela tarihte aklınıza gelen meşhur
kadınlar diye Kiminiz mesela Kleopatra
diyebilir değil mi Ama kleopatrayı biz
tarihte E işte Marcus antonius'la
verdiği partilerden işte yaptığı
makyajlardan biliyoruz keza Nefer titi
öyle
eee
benim çok sevdiğim Reşat Ekrem koçu
İstanbul ansiklopedisinin yazarı
haşmetli yosmalar diye bir kitap yazmış
düşünün yani kadın tarihine dair ve
orada da Eee bu meşhur tarihi figürleri
kadınları resmen böyle entrikacı
Eee saltanatları bitiren Eee işte
haremlerde türlü oyunlar oynayan Eee ve
dolayısıyla Aslında her zaman bir
pejoratif eee bir anlam yükleyerek
kaleme alıyorlar kadınlar saltanatı diye
de bir kitap var bilirsiniz Bu sadece
Bizde böyle değil Şimdi batıya bakınca
da aynı şey söz konusu zaten kadın
tarihi gender studies başlığı altında
1960'larda ortaya çıkmış bir mevzu
düşünün yani 300.000 yıllık bir homo
sapien tarihine bakıyoruz ve bu 300.000
yıllık tarihte ki ilk kadının Afrika'dan
çıktığını
eee biliyoruz hepimiz onun torunlarıyız
e ve yani 300 b000 yıllık tarihte
kadınla ilgili yazılmaya başladığı andan
itibaren kadın yasalarda eğitim hakkında
vesaire her yerde bir şekilde Eee
silinmiş ya da yok edilmiş Ben de bunun
üzerine işte bahsettiğim gibi
kadınlardan bahsedilse bile her zaman
birisinin eşi sevgilisi kızı olarak
ortaya çıkıyor
eee çok güçlü Kadınlar genellikle hep
böyle ya cadılıkla E
ya gücünü kötüye kullanmakla ya da çok
müstesna böyle bir anomali olarak
karşımıza çıkıyor E bunları gördükçe Ben
de dedim ki alternatif tarih nedir acaba
kadın ne zaman gerçek anlamda kaybetti
matriarki denilen kadın Egemen bir
toplum var mıydı Peki varsa da patriarki
yani erkek Egemen düzene ne zaman
geçildi bunu tabii ki ben ilk sormadım
mesela bachofen diye bir Roma hukukçusu
vardır 1861'de Çok önemli bir kitap
kaleme alıyor ve bu aile mezunu ailenin
tarihine irdelemeye
başlıyor ve baş ofen ondan feyz alarak
ve etkilenen engels Aslında günümüzde
bile yani aradan 100 yıldan daha fazla
zaman
geçmiş hala onlarla bir Polemik halinde
kadın çalışmaları onların söylediğini
kanıtlamak Ya Da Toprağın altına gömmek
onla bir didişme tarihinden bahsediyoruz
Niye Çünkü önce başfen sonra engels bu
benim demin bahsettiğim soruyu sormuşlar
yani kadın ne zaman kaybetti ya da kadın
bir Fi tarihinde o hepimizin bildiği
böyle kahramanlık olarak dillendirdiği
amazonları ve benzeri kadın savaşçıları
ve topluluklarını
irdeliyor
şimdi özellikle başfen ve engels
baktığımızda şöyle bir teori görüyoruz
ki hala buna İnananlar var ama buna
inanmayanlar da var açacağım boş fen ve
engel şuna inanıyor her şey muhteşemdi
kadınlar için kadınlar Avcı toplayıcı
Eee zamanlarda yani yerleşik düzene
geçmeden tarıma geçmeden
Eee erkeklerle birlikte mücadele
ediyordu birlikte avlanıyor lardı ki
zırt bırt avlanıyor lardı homo sapien
çok iyi bir Avcı evet ama yani e haftada
bir falan
avlanmalar gösteriyor ki Ortalama bir
avcı toplayıcı topluluğu Eee ayda bir
avlanıyor Ee yine bu antropologlar şunu
kanıtlıyor Avcı toplayıcı topluluklarda
o kabilenin ya da o topluluğun var
oluşunu sürdürebilir sağlayan Aslında
Kadınlar % 60 işi kadınlar yapıyor Çünkü
sadece avlanmakla bitmiyor kaldı ki
Sadece erkekler de avlanıyor Hani güçlü
erkek avlanıyor O yüzden güçlü oldu
tezini çökertiyor diyorlar ki kadın
erkek birlikte avlanıyor kadın da iyi
bir avcı O da işte hayvanları
vurabiliyor onun ötesinde
işte sepet yapmak mı deriden kıyafet
dikmek mi değişik bitkileri ayırt edip
otlardan ve işte bitkilerden yemek
yapmak mı çocuğa bakmak mı yani o kabile
kadın olmazsa yok olur diyen pek çok
antropolog var günümüzde ki engels ve
başefendi bu tezin alt yapısını
oluşturuyorlar Hatta şunu söyleyeyim
Bugün göz üzerine retina üzerine ve renk
üzerine çalışan bilim insanları şunu
söylüyor Bazı kadınlar erkeklerden 100
kat daha fazla renk görüyor bunu
bilimsel olarak kanıtlayabilir Neden
Çünkü bizim analarımız o iki yeşilin
arasındaki ton farkını göremez bütün
topluluk zehirlenebilir Dolayısıyla Biz
yeşilin Kırmızının pek çok rengin
arasındaki tonajı ayırt etmek zorundayız
Çünkü o kabilenin yaşamı ya da ölümü söz
konusu o küçük e zehiri yakalayıp
yakalamakla ilgili bu vel asıl kelam bu
müthiş ütopik güzel kadınların güçlü
olduğu Avcı toplayıcı
Eee topluluklarda kadın erkek eşit ve bu
eee kimi Eee arkeoloğa göre işte ana
tanrıçaların dönemi yani o ilk başta
bahsettiğim Selanik'teki kadın
arkeologların Eee böyle huşu içinde
bahsettiği ana tanrıçalar dönemi yani
Mezopotamya da İnana e sümerlerin
inanası sonra oluyor İştar E işte Kibele
Anadolu'nun en önemli tanrıçalar andan
bir tanesi Artemis
Hera Demeter
persefoni yani tanrıçalar sayarak bitmez
Ama bu tanrıçalar bir taraftan çok güçlü
Eee onlar adına pek çok tapınak var ama
bir taraftan da bu tanrıçalar öldürücü
de olabiliyor Tıpkı Doğa gibi
Dolayısıyla kali denilen o Eee hintlerin
ana tanrıçalar andan bir tanesi kana
doymuyor depremler yapıyor tepindi yi
anda Eee bizim Anadolu'daki ana Tanrı
çalarımı da bir taraftan doğurgan işte
çatal oyukta gördüğümüz gibi geniş
kalçalı Hayat bağış ediyor ama istediği
anda da
Eee işte çam ağacının hikayesi Oradan
gelir avlanan Eee erkekleri anına da
köpeklerine
parçalatan ana tanrıçalar teori şu bu
Avcı toplayıcılar en sonunda yine her
şey Anadolu'ya bağlanıyor tarım Dünyanın
değişik yerlerinde başlıyor Ama buğday
ilk kez göbeklitepe'nin 50 km ötesinde
Eee kültive ediliyor
Avcı toplayıcılar tarım e dünyasına
giriyorlar ve tarıma tarım sistemine
geçtiği anda kadın evinin metası oluyor
ve hapsediliyor deniliyor Dolayısıyla
ilk yasalarımıza baktığınızda hamurabi
kodları olsun e draco'nun kodları olsun
Antik Yunan'da Mezopotamya'da hepsinde
kadın e bir şekilde Eee babadan eşe
geçirilen bir Meta olarak kabul ediliyor
kadın Eee eski çağlarda eğitimden mahrum
bırakılıyor kadın miras haklarından
mahrum ediliyor yani sonun başlangıcı
pek çok teorisyen göre bu tarım
toplumundan dolayı Çünkü insanlar
yerleşik üzerine geçince kadının rolü
sadece ailede çocuk bakmak oluyor ve
verilen eğitim de Eee Ancak hani Eee o
küçük çocukları birazcık daha eğitecek
daha böyle sorumlu vatandaş yapacak
kadar Ama daha fazlası tehlikeli Çünkü
daha fazlasını verince hipat gibi
tarihin ilk
bilimsel şehitlerinden bir tanesi ortaya
çıkıyor nee lazım Çok eğitimli kadınlar
tehlikeli dişli oluyorlar sistemi
zorluyorlar patriarki
indirebilirler şimdi bu teori kulağa çok
güzel geliyor ve bir taraftan da ben
inanmak istiyorum Ama özellikle dediğim
gibi 60'lardan itibaren kadın
çalışmalarındaki pek çok Eee akademisyen
antropolog sosyolog Tarihçi Yazar bunu
sorgulamaya başladı Bir tanesi mesela
diyor ki Tamam çok güzel bş ofen engels
işte her şeyi E bu ekonomiye bağladı
tarım sistemine geçmeye bağladı ama
onlar kadın haklarını savunuyor muydu Yo
kendilerinden 1 yıl önce 1500 önce Eee o
bizim bayıldığımız filozoflarının
söylemleri Aslında tekrarlıyor Ben
mesela aristo'yu çok severim değil mi
Hani felsefe tarihi deyince en önemli
filozoflardan bir tanesidir ama
Aristo yazdık yazdığında kadınlarla
ilgili kadın eksik erkektir diye yazan
bir yazar çünkü o dönemin antik yunanı
kadına eksik erkek ya da tam
Tamamlanmamış e olmamış erkek olarak
görüyor ki kilise babaları
ST Thomas aqu
e ya da sa augustin gibi orta çağlardan
itibaren kilisenin bütün felsefesini
oluşturan Yazarlar da bunu tekrarlayıp E
daha böyle hani kadın düşmanlığını
sistematik hale Getiriyorlar guttenberg
devriminden önce biliyorsunuz e o kerik
Yani manastırlarda insanlar aynı şeyi
böyle kopyalıyor lardı orada eee e kadın
azizeler e önemli İşte İsa'nın
havarilerine kadar kadınların sistematik
olarak silindiğini bugün kilise tarihi
çalışan herkes kabul ediyor Eee ki
isimleriyle kabul ediyor ilk kopyaları
diyelim incillerin milattan sonra 200'e
doğru gidiyor o hepimizin bildiği Dead
Sea scrolls Ölü Deniz scrollar onlara
bakıyorsunuz Orada mesela önemli kadın
rolleri var 200 yıl sonraya gidiyor
birdenbire o kilise babaları ya da
onların akoli yardımcıları silmişler
Dolayısıyla dinler tarihinde de böyle
siyasi tarihte de böyle kadınlar
silinmiş Böylece bakıyoruz
Aslında engels'in dediği gibi her şey
ekonomi ile ilgili kapitalist sistemi
yıkarsanız kadınlar bir gün tekrar
güçlenir diye bir vizyona sahip ki
1917'de Ruslar devrim yap yca Eee bunu
da Hayal etmişler ama sonra diyelim e
konay gibi önemli kadınlar birlikte
Devrim yaparken güzel ama ondan sonra
böyle elçiliklere tayin edilip E çok
konuşuyor çok tehlikeli diye o sistem
bile Devrim yapan ve kadınları
güçlendiren ve 8 Mart'ın kutlanmasını
sağlayan o Clara zetkin ve konay gibi
kadınlar da tarih sahnesinden periferiye
itilmiş keza Fransız devrim Fransız
devrimini gerçekleştiren sadece robes
Pier mara gibi devrimciler değil olym da
gu gibi bir kadın var mesela o tiyatro
oyunları yazıyor çok gerçekten acayip
bir kadın ve Devrim öncesinde diyor ki
işte Biz devrim yapınca kadınlar ve
erkekler eşit olacak sonra Devrim oluyor
o devrimciler kadın haklarını
unutuyorlar sonra olimp de g gidiyor
bakın bildirg demiz var diyor Bu böyle
bir vaat vardı diyor giyotine
gönderiyorlar ama olimp gooj
da
kutlanması 1789'da sonra 2000'lerin
sonuna doğru geliyor keza
mariu şimdi mariu deyince hepimiz
biliriz değil mi Belki dünyada fizik ve
kimyada Nobel
almış ilk kadın ol olmanın ötesinde ilk
Bilim insanlarından bir tanesi ama
Paris'te uzun protestolar sonrası
Paris metrosunda kocası Pierre K'nin
yanına ismi yerleştirildi Bu da 2007
yılında ya düşünün böyle hani ünlü
önemli kadınlar başarılı kadınlar bile
bir şekilde hep ikinci plana
itiliyor Şimdi gelelim çok az bir zaman
kaldı bu
kadınların kaybedip kaybetmediğini benen
ve engels'in ve ondan sonra gelen Simon
de bov gibi dzy seksi yazan insanlar
gibi e doğru bir yere işaret ettiğini
düşünüyorum ama bugünkü antropologlar ve
Arkeologlar diyorlar ki aslında kadın
hiçbir zaman böyle matriarkal böyle çok
güçlü O ana tanrıçaları tapıldı
zamanlardaki gibi tarım topluma geçmeden
önce
Eee böyle bir bir yerde oturuyordu Ondan
sonra tarımla bir ilkte bitti Bu tezi bu
günümüzde inanılm Neden Çünkü Vietnam
gibi İşte kong'daki bazı yerler gibi Eee
dünyanın çeşitli yerlerinde kadının
güçlü olduğu topluluklara bakınca Şunu
fark ediyorlar kadın güçlü olunca ezmi
yani o Amazon Miti ki akropolü işte
üzerine nakş edilmiş Antik Yunan'da
sayısız Vazoda vesaire amazonları
görüyoruz ama arkeolojik kazılar bize
diyor ki büyük bir ihtimalle Kuzey
Karadeniz'de iskitlerin olduğu o
kadınlar Evet Ata biniyordu erkeklerle
birlikte savaşıyordu ama o kadınlar işte
herodot'un iddia ettiği gibi Eee
erkekleri
katletmiş olduğu topluluklarda zamanım
bitti kadınlar egaliteryan yani
eşitlikçi bundan sonra da Eee ben
çağımızın değişeceğini düşünüyorum Bu
teorilerin dibinde bir doğruluk payı var
Eee ama kadınlar hiçbir zaman iddia
ettikleri gibi çok güçlü ve çok Erk
sahibi
olmamışlar Ama bundan sonra olacaklar ve
bunu Biz başaracağız Çok teşekkür ederim